es la primera prohibición de este tipo
el gobernador de Montana Greg jeanforte
ha firmado una ley que prohíbe la
plataforma china tiktok en el estado
tiktok es solo una aplicación vinculada
a adversarios extranjeros hoy ordenado
al director de información del estado
que prohíba cualquier aplicación que
proporcione información o datos
personales adversarios extranjeros desde
la red Estatal la prohibición que
entrará en vigor el 1 de enero de 2000 a
24 y legalizará que las tiendas de
aplicaciones de Apple y Google permitan
la descarga de tiktok en el estado
aunque no habrá sanciones para quienes
utilicen la aplicación
la polémica en torno a tiktok comenzó en
noviembre cuando surgieron
preocupaciones de seguridad sobre la
propiedad parcial del gobierno chino de
otra empresa perteneciente a byte Dance
matriz de tiktok la empresa tecnológica
china ha tratado de restar importancia a
la conexión con el partido comunista
insistiendo en que la participación no
tiene ninguna relación con las
operaciones globales de byte dance a
fuera de China Incluyendo a tiktok pero
varios gobiernos internacionales no
están convencidos y han prohibido la
aplicación en dispositivos federales
también han surgido dudas sobre el
impacto de la aplicación en la salud
mental de los jóvenes y sobre la
información que recopila y comparte con
casi la mitad de los 3 a 30 millones de
estadounidenses en tiktok la red social
afirma que la nueva legislación infringe
los derechos de la primera enmienda del
pueblo de Montana es muy probable que la
ley enfrente varios inconvenientes
legales que podrían llegar a anular la
prohibición antes de que entre en vi